[Musik]
findet es sie nicht dass ich hier schon
ziemlich tolle dino knochen ausgegraben
haben dann für heizung zu museen
in berlin geboren
[Musik]
der sommer war so kurz und verregnet
dass erich lange zeit gar nicht
wahrhaben wollte dass der herbst schon
vor der tür steht und ja es hat ein
bisschen wehgetan die tomaten zu
entsorgen aber als ich dann dabei war
habe ich gemerkt wie befreit das auch
ist die garten jetzt in die winterzeit
zu schicken und das die ganzen ein koch
und firmen marathons es langsam zur ruhe
kommen die ernte eingefahren ist und wie
diese pause bekommen die ich gerade
wirklich wirklich gut gebrauchen kann
natürlich ist das gärtner das schönste
hobby unter diesem himmel gar keine
frage aber es tut so gut zu wissen dass
wir in den nächsten drei monaten weniger
im garten zu tun haben und diese pause
bekommen damit wir im frühjahr dann
wieder ganz motiviert durchstarten
können
wir bauen im winter immer noch super
viele leckere gemüse an aber die arbeit
hat sich doch wie eingrenzen im prinzip
ist neben ernten und das gemüse ein
murmeln und vor frost schützen dann bald
nicht mehr so viel zu tun und das ist
total schön
hier draußen
gucken was diese ruhe bringt solange
diese ladies hier mich weiterhin so
auftraten
[Musik]
und das liegt vor allem an dieser süßen
schnute hier katja heißt sie und sogar
liegt wie sie aussieht zu faustdick
hinter den ohren weil sie einfach über
jeden sommer kommt und sobald sie drüben
ist geht es mit den anderen natürlich
auch durch dann wollen die auch abbauen
und rennt einfach in den zaun rein weil
sie nach draußen wollen dass es wirklich
wirklich ruhig weil es derzeit
der frauen steht ihnen ein
jeder bekommt rein das gute ist dass
immer wieder reingehen von selber als
ganzes zu tun als ob ich das nicht
angehen würde
[Musik]
tipp nicht immer mit ihrem
gestreichelt werden wird
so niedlich in solchen momenten wünsche
ich mir so sehr einen eigenen bauernhof
wo ich feste zäune bauen kann und nicht
mehr auf diese elektronische angewiesen
bin
irgendwann irgendwann
[Musik]
hier seht schon welche
diese woche es bei uns erst angekündigt
deswegen bin ich bei der koch auf damit
beschäftigt die ganze wärme liebenden
genieße abzuernten damit sie nicht
erfrieren
[Musik]
und die frei gewordenen biete werden in
der viele legt sofort in der folge plant
[Musik]
wenn das wetter ist irgendwie zulässt
dann versuche ich so viel zeit wie
möglich draußen zu verbringen weil ich
mir geht dass sich das im moment so art
brauche viele von euch wissen
wahrscheinlich dass ich kurse zum
gärtnern und zum haltbarmachen bernd in
liebe und das ist ein projekt in dem
ganz viel leidenschaft und herzblut von
mir steckt und in den letzten vier
jahren habe ich unfassbar viel zeit und
energie in die kurse gesteckt weil ich
will dass so viele menschen wie möglich
rausgehen und ihr eigenes essen anbauen
und trotzdem merke ich dass ich mich in
letzter zeit sehr über anstrengend habe
und ich hatte auch kaum noch zeit für
meine familie und freunde und bin sogar
fast nicht mehr dazu gekommen in meinem
eigenen garten zu sein und das kann
nicht wirklich der sinn dahinter sein
deswegen nehme ich mir diese zeit jetzt
einfach und versuche irgendwie wieder
aufzutanken
und wie ist es da drin
ja
mainz mit sparsamen 1
[Musik]
und irgendwann vor ein paar wochen habe
ich dann gemerkt da ist egal wie durch
dieser sommer war die herbst ist
unglaublich schön dieses jahr und
vielleicht ist es dieses jahr umso
wichtiger jeden einzelnen sonnenstrahl
einzufangen bevor der winter kommt
[Musik]
auf jeden fall habe ich jetzt jemanden
ganz in der nähe mit dem in den keller
ist richtig schön genießen kann
demnächst es nämlich gezogen steckt
immer vor
dazu laufen oder ich werde euch in jedes
kanal unten in der video beschreibung
falls sie ihn noch nicht kennt schaut
auf jeden fall vorbei das lohnt sich
[Musik]
nur wir gerade dabei waren den herbst zu
preisen ist es nicht total schön wenn es
draußen so richtig ungemütlich ist die
reden ganz gemütliche sachen zu machen
wie kekse zu backen eine kerze
anzuzünden
einen heißen kakao zu schlürfen und zu
wissen dass man überhaupt nicht
rausgehen muss irgendwie hat das auch
was
[Musik]
geträumt ich müsste für mein buch auf so
eine veranstaltung wie die made gala
oder für so ein riesending durch keine
ahnung was ist eigentlich minister und
dann waren das im katharina und der
verleger und so weiter und billy eilig
hatte ort abgehalten und ich mussten
wollen wir nägel machen lassen das dann
so schwartze jeden liegen mit grünen
glitzer trauer und dann will ich gesehen
dass fünf von mega gar nicht machbar ich
habe das irgendwie selber gerne trägt
man hat sie gesagt weißt du wie ich mir
da habe
ich gesagt berlin ehrlich gesagt
[Musik]
die minen sind hier direkt am büro und
ich habe gesehen dass eine henne sobald
ich das erkennen und hat zumindest die
gehen nicht so gut als dass sich nehmen
jetzt noch mal nach hause und packt die
badewanne was hier los ist wenn das
bäuchlein in der hoffnung dass es
weitergeht man sieht es ja irgendwie am
gesichtsausdruck an die großtat sich
aufsaugen
[Musik]
danke
- piraten morgen fahre ich zu einem mann
der uns einen neuen hühnerstall baut und
der wild wunderschönen wir machen das in
dem schrein ex zusammen damit wir
gleichzeitig baupläne für euch
entwickeln können und das möglichst
einfach für euch ist den herstellern
nachzubauen und bleibst hier weil morgen
konnten noch mal gewartet
[Musik]
aber was ist noch zu jung für die
schublade oder auch schon geplant
[Musik]
doch
selbst ein bisschen in hand voll mit
wasser macht dass sie nicht mehr kriegen
können
[Musik]
doch das einzige südlichen
japan ein
[Musik]
dann bringt die kranken durch noch ein
telefon mit frisuren
was könnten wir noch gutes tun für unser
krankes mädchen
fest ich muss allein lassen ja ich
glaube
beim baden ist mir dann aufgefallen dass
sagt ihn nicht nur legend hat sondern
auch eine kopf verstopfung das ist gar
nicht lustig bei hühnern kommt aber
immer mal wieder vor so dass wir dann
auch ja die hühner leckerlis weggelassen
haben weniger getreide gefüttert haben
sie hat knoblauch wasser bekommen
regelmäßige massagen damit der kopf
irgendwie lockerer wird wir haben auch
versuchte sie sich über gebt alles in
absprache mit dem tier ist natürlich das
hat überhaupt nicht geklappt also drückt
auf jeden fall die daumen dass sie das
schafft sie hat es auf jeden fall nicht
leicht gerade
[Musik]
ein anderes zeichen dafür dass der
winter vor der tür steht ist dass die
ziehen in die winterquartiere gezogen
sind die heuballen wurde geliefert und
damit es die weide sie soll jetzt so gut
wie vorbei
[Musik]
wir sind noch fleißig mit nüsse sammeln
beschäftigt und mit einlagern auch die
erd- meter fit ist wieder aktiviert und
ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass in den
nächsten wochen auch der eine oder
andere tochter geboten marmelade auf dem
herd stehen wird ja und dann gucken wir
mal ob das was will mit der winterruhe
ich glaube ja fast
[Musik]
liga
ein
als kate
lieber
die
[Musik]